[Music]
Union organizing is difficult in the
United States
it is a knock down drag out fight going
on now at Several of these companies and
particularly at Starbucks
[Music]
a lot of people had the perception that
you know this company was too big to
take on strong unions are a vital part
of rebuilding the declining middle class
in this country
Consulting makes a union campaign more
successful because assault is usually
able to keep things underground to get
enough people on board that by the time
the company finds out about the union
campaign it's too late
businesses hate salting more than they
hate termites or shoplifters companies
see salts as infiltrators
[Music]
the share of the private sector U.S
workplace that is organized by labor
unions has plummeted the past year and a
half has seen a startling shift we've
seen stunning victories at places like
Amazon Trader Joe's Apple Chipotle REI
and in some ways most strikingly at
Starbucks where we've gone from zero
unionized corporate run U.S Starbucks
hundreds often salting is a key tactic
in an organizing campaign salting means
getting hired undercover at a company in
order to organize there
I wanted to Salt originally because my
mother was in the restaurant industry
her whole life she worked as a manager
was putting in 72-hour weeks and she was
diagnosed with a stage 3 ovarian cancer
she like a lot of people in the service
industry didn't have health care she
spent most of her savings trying to
fight that battle and you know by the
time she died there was hardly anything
left
that's wrong that's not the world that I
want to live in anything that I could do
to improve that was something that I was
willing to do
salting has been a tactic used by Union
organizers for more than a century
the term salting is said to come from
the idea of salting the mine when
someone would put Gold Dust into a mine
to trick a purchaser
I'm Jazz press hack my job is to help
workers who don't have unions get unions
so this was the original job posting to
advertise for inside organizers to come
to Buffalo we ended up having a team of
about 10 inside organizers
they reached out and said hey I was
curious if there was something to work
on the summer through Workers United
Jess said would you be willing to go
into Starbucks in Buffalo and I said
I'll apply right now I got myself hired
by playing a role I was incredibly
passionate about Starbucks and I was
incredibly Smiley incredibly gentle in
the interviews I drafted a cover letter
talking about how I believed in a future
at Starbucks that involved me just
trying to capture the different check
marks that managers are looking for you
know talking about the business as a
family and tried to present the most
palatable employee to management that
they could have and
it always works
[Music]
companies of course don't like salting
companies see salts as infiltrators who
lied to them and they're lying to their
co-workers and in the service of taking
away the company's authority over how
the business should be run
I defy anyone who says that you know
assault is a fake Barista so these are
the drink recipe cards from Starbucks
these were the basis for training new
inside organizers on
you know how to make sure that they were
up to speed on the recipes and the
proportions
the whole point of becoming an inside
organizer is that you are actually able
to both do the job and build the trust
necessary with co-workers to be able to
organize and you can't do that by being
bad at your job you have to take some
time to get to know people build
relationships and get to the place where
you can start a union safely and you can
actually get to a union election
salting is going through a Renaissance
now in the United States Advocates and
experts on all sides of this have said
it seems to be more people salting right
now in the United States than we've seen
in the past couple decades
I don't think there's any company that
you could insult from you know the
United firm workers to the Building
Trades to the service industry to
manufacturing the goal should be to
organize every company Union organizers
in part through effective use of
assaulting tactic have pulled off
spectacular victories
but none of them has a collective
bargaining agreement
you shouldn't have to have gone through
the hell that we did by the company in
order to leave our rights
rights and to bargain with them but the
fact that we were able to work together
in tandem meant everything it means that
now we can bargain
the big question is can these workers
win Union contracts and what will those
contracts be
Consulting is one of the hardest ways to
organize but it's also the most
effective way because the people who are
willing to Salt are the ones who are
actually willing to learn a job become
one of the people and then build a union
and help organize I think that's one of
the most you know selfless things that
people can do we need to make sure that
the majority of the workforce is better
taken care of and the best way to do
that is through unionizing and getting
contracts and guarantees to increase
wages increase benefits it's worth doing
and continuing to put pressure on
companies everywhere to do better by
their workers
[Music]